a lógica do mundo não vale pra mãe não a
mãe tem a lógica dela e na lógica das
mãe se ela guardar as panelas ninguém
mais pode comer nada em casa ca chega em
casa 11 hor da noite morrendo de fome se
o cara esquentar um leite para tomar tu
já vai comer Ave Maria esse M Parece que
tem uma barriga nos Oli é por isso que
não sobra nada aqui em casa vocês comem
tudo de noite outra lógica de mãe o caba
tá doente ele não pode fazer nada fica
ali sentado fica ali sentado se deita
dorme agora é o seguinte se o caba der
um sorriso é porque tá bom caba doente a
mãe do lado assistindo televisão
soltaram uma piada Ah e tu tá é bom que
tá aí todo sorrindo caminha vai lavar
louça porque a mãe não pode ver um filho
bom e parado não tem que est fazendo
alguma coisa é por isso que quando eu
fic perto da minha mãe eu fico assim ó ó
ó fico me mechendo aqui para não ficar
parado